so what other arcs are there
well like i said the trolling one feels
like it lasts forever yeah the initial i
mean the equestria is always being
trolled with that never stopped though
it didn't really but there was like
worse i feel like it was like the fourth
ninja war argument
just kept going yeah yeah it's like the
manga arc that you wish ended like 10
years ago that just kept on going and
like you know there's some really
abhorrent trolling that was was done and
again like some of it is so bad that i
do
still feel sorry for chris like uh you
know wouldn't he shove stuff up his um
you know his uh
member at the time
of his member did he do that or was it
his past it was the butthole
which isn't very good
yeah but yeah this was a very
unfortunate very dark episode in chris's
life where where chris believed that
their e-girlfriend at the time was being
kidnapped
by their evil brother or whatever
and um also their their playstation
network account was also being hacked
and held hostage so chris had to choose
which one would you prefer to save your
girlfriend or your psn account at which
um they chose chris chose the girlfriend
but by choosing so chris believed that
they would get both because he mean
because they made the right choice
like like a bible like uh
you made the right choice exactly yeah
the five pounds yeah it's the money of
the bible the money of the bible you get
both if you pick the bible
but yeah during during the course of
this of this uh of this debacle um chris
was tasked with either i think burning
their sanitary medallion which they
which they fashioned out of a
like play-doh or a clay yeah very iconic
piece of
either either either burn it or
put it up their butthole
so
chris chose to you know cut it up into
smaller pieces first because it was too
big oh oh of course of course totally
don't burn it at that point you know
it's already destroyed but don't burn it
put it on your butt
you can put it back together afterwards
what was that what was the logic behind
cutting it up instead of burning it is
ever explained uh no no
it's just like what if you're destroying
it why not
choose the option of destroying it
because you can still put it back
together right maybe
thinking maybe chris thought that they
didn't have access to matches oh
one of the it's one of the most biggest
plot points in the whole story we
haven't even got to the plot twist
i'm so invested it's it's like one of
the like most well-known parts of the
story i might notice
we'll talk about later it's in part 39
by the way
i remember because this was the part
that i was waiting for to happen because
i'd heard so much about it and i wanted
to know i know it's insane it's insane
so
yeah there's chris put the thing up
their butt and filmed it and obviously
in your version you censor it for that
um i i believe it was like a skype call
or something um so so the person acting
as as the girlfriend and also the evil
twin brother
they were the same 13 year old boy by
the way 13 year old boy 13 year old boy
doing this
what so yeah
after after
the shoving
um they revealed themselves to be a 13
year old boy and that the girl never
existed which was just which distraught
chris there were other yeah naturally
yeah there were other members of that at
the trolling group in the call but but
just listening and you know being being
muted but after that they they came out
and said jesus stop like they knew yeah
i remember this yeah they knew that this
boy went way too far obviously yeah yeah
it's it's so disgusting that you know
that only like a sick kid would ask
someone to do this yeah when i was 13 i
think i was just
playing jenga or something i don't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing i certainly
wasn't thinking about that i wonder like
how do these kids do this that's like
throughout this thing it's almost as
much as chris was doing some really
abhorrent stuff
i always find that everyone involved was
also
very guilty of doing some really heinous
things yeah and it felt like anyone who
went near
this like cesspit of drama was just
dragged into doing really horrible stuff
honestly it just sounds the entire thing
just sounds like a [ __ ] show like
[Music]
it is the worst part of the internet in
every aspect it shows every single
terrible thing a troll can do
it shows the terrible nature of what
feeding trolls does yeah you know i i
don't think there's and that's why it's
almost hard to look away because it's so
fascinating such a magnificent train
crash right that you just like
it's like it's like the train crashes
and does 10 back flips and then lands
and then catches fire yeah it's just
almost like everything that
it's just so insane and i think that's
why again you should go and watch gino's
uh video on it on videos wait well hold
on like you guys you guys like blue
balls with this like plot point okay i
need some so there's the whole trolling
yeah so so the so the trolling with the
with the fake girlfriends thing went on
for quite a while uh pretty much until
chris's father died right uh when he was
when this was two years right
about two or three years yeah so after
that they decided you know
let's leave chris alone
you know they've suffered enough i guess
i guess that was there there are things
yeah two years later i think we've done
enough damage i think this is enough
like it's like you should have been
stopped at the medallion
yeah so so there was a solid year where
chris didn't do much except occasional
facebook posts
uh yeah and then fast forward to 2014
where in the middle of the night
chris was i believe trying to make a cup
of coffee
and uh
the extension cable which which
connected to their coffee maker uh it
was like draped over over the bathroom
door
and like the constant opening closing
like
damaged the wire yeah it caught fire the
house caught fire
yeah it was a you also have to
understand that at this time chris's
house is a hoarder's house yeah right so
you know when you hoard stuff your house
just goes up in flames yeah of course
that was the problem as the reason why
this was so jank and the reason why the
coffee machine was so [ __ ] to begin
with is because there was no floor space
right right and i believe there was two
or three cats
inside this hoarder's house
did the cats i don't know if the cats i
assume the cats unfortunately didn't
make it one cat dies
now i'm sad that's like that's what's so
sad about this is that you know in some
aspects you kind of don't feel sorry
that chris
ruined their own life you know because
you almost you know this is done by
yourself yeah but i think the the most
unfortunate part about this is
not only is uh our chris's parents and
dragged into all of this mess but also
pets as well yeah just like other you
know like innocent bystanders just got
involved you know this manager got ran
over you know there's many points in
this story that are so sad just for
again it's like a vacuum if you're
involved with chris in any way generally
not good stuff was happening
um yeah and the hoarder's house there's
pictures out there i'm assuming we could
you can show it on screen right it's
totally fine yeah probably fine it's
fine this is what it looks like it's
pretty bad it's very very so was chris
the hoarder or was it chris was mostly
not the hoarder actually chris's room
was the most
right it was it was chris's mother yeah
she was the hoarder and um
actually
actually uh resulted in the pretty i
guess infamous video of uh
of chris who after after posting a house
tour video on youtube
um
which is insane to think that you would
post a tour of that yeah right
for uh for a girl obviously right
girl
as far as chris knew um
chris's father found out
and uh demanded that chris take down the
video off of the internet which was kind
of an impossible task yeah
yeah and then during during the
recording session where where chris was
shouting at the camera and all the
trolls to take it down now now now now
now
um
chris's father walks in and they have
this little discussion
about um chris saying uh about um about
chris's father saying you know if the if
the health department sees this video
we're gonna we're gonna be evicted you
know you just you just you just stuck a
knife in our bags and killed us with
your video is what he said yeah so it's
very
jesus yeah crazy video on your own when
you're watching this video uh i i you
have to watch the video to get a real
horrible sense of scale this it is
essentially like a jungle gym you can't
like even the camera doesn't you can't
see anything right junk everywhere
and it's just too zoomed in yeah so
every time you're like looking around
you can't get a sense of scale of
anything because it's just so much stuff
and obviously you know hoarder's houses
are uh basically just what fire hazards
i mean that's the reason why you get
evicted because you can't do that at all
that's exactly what happens right
cockroaches
also i believe the cats were also sick
at the time is that right or they
weren't i wouldn't be surprised
they're healthy yeah they were later
there were other new later cats who
became sick in the house yeah right i i
remember watching a video when they
moved to the new place which was given
was it provided by the government there
was a there was a new temporary rental
place yeah that was provided by the
house insurance uh
and uh yeah i remember there was a point
in this video where you could hear the
cat and it sounded like it was dying
it sounded very bad dogs too yeah the
dogs as well right
no leave the animals yeah right it's a
horrible story you know and i think it
puts into it you often ask the question
of like how ethical is it to
watch all this stuff and document it and
talk about it is that something you
often struggle with when you're um yeah
making these videos i i do yeah yeah
well i think one thing about your video
that i could get is that it seemed like
you weren't it was it was just pure
documentation right you weren't putting
your opinion into it it was just pure
this is what happened and this is just a
pure documentation of things you can
already find on the internet yeah it's
kind of just like you know just laying
out the information and kind of leaving
it up to the viewer to make their own
opinions about the whole
case what better way right
because i think that's what really
attracted me to your videos is that yeah
again there was just no no input from
you but also made you a kind of a
mysterious figure yeah you always start
the video saying like who who is chris
what drives i'm like who's gino
why is he making this video
which is why i wanted to bring you on
because i really wanted to learn more
about you as well and what drives you to
make these videos because i feel like
you know it takes a it takes a mental
toll i imagine having to document this
stuff and there are some lines that you
have to say out loud because you narrate
chris's words
and i there's some very funny out of
context clips of you being like just
shouting really funny stuff putting
stuff up your ass
i said sorry i hate to do you like that
it's just the burden he has to bear yeah
it was the burden at which point were
you just like committed to like i mean i
mean yeah yeah
that way you were just committed to i
assume completing this thing i mean
you've gotten this far right i mean i
was committed since the beginning yeah i
imagine just i was i was not expecting
this to last this long unfortunately
yeah but
i do understand that some parts may be a
bit boring for some and just the
constant maybe facebook like
readings of of a facebook posts or
tweets for example which i do cut down
as well but
i find it interesting and relevant to
the story which is uh which is a
kind of community it's kind of a
conflict every anime has its filler yeah
i find that's what makes your videos so
compelling is that it almost feels like
no stone is left unturned like every
single thing is included is that fair to
say that you include pretty much
everything um
not really oh really most things most
things things that are really not
interesting or not relevant to the
story then yeah i do skip over them so
how much how much stuff is you know when
you you have the episode yeah how much
stuff in in between like tweets or
facebook posts is cut like if you had to
give like a ratio of like how much
information makes it in to not in the
video possibly about one percent doesn't
make it out
so nearly everything else goes in yeah
it's like literally everything goes in
all right wow i mean it depends on on
how much detail
i'm on how much time i spend on it like
for example if it's a
vaguely interesting tweet for example i
just mentioned that that chris talked
about this or like if it's if it's more
compelling if it's more interesting i
just read word for word most of it for
example so i spend more because i was
about to say like if you had said like
oh about 20 that would be like jesus how
much content
is there on this person like a worrying
amount right like i already watch your
videos and i go my god this is more
information than you know several
generation families that
have on the internet let alone just this
one single person